i do have the most amazing wonderful
perfect most beautiful girlfriend in the
whole world
jojo siwa just revealed she's in a
relationship
i'm so excited for it so good the 17
year old star dropped the news that she
has a girlfriend
during an appearance on the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon on wednesday
about 10 minutes before i came out to do
this interview today
i was again on the phone with with my
girl
and i started crying and she's like
what's wrong with you
and i was like i'm just so happy i was
like because now i get to share
what makes me the happiest with the
world and it makes my heart so happy
jojo who came out as a member of the
lgbtq community last month
didn't reveal the identity of her
partner but she did say this
i do have the most amazing wonderful
perfect most beautiful girlfriend in the
whole world
and this we're on the phone literally 24
7 both of our families get
so annoyed at us oh my god cute
i love love i feel awesome like it's so
epic just to think that like this is my
life the nickelodeon star also opened up
about her decision to publicly come out
i was doing tick tocks with the people
who are in the pride house that's like
what their tick-tock house is called is
the pride house
and i love them i've known them all for
years and so we were like let's just do
some tick tocks together before i leave
for canada
and they come over and we're doing this
tic tac and i was like i think
this tic tac that we're doing to ain't
it fun i was like i think this is gonna
out me
just in case you missed it this is the
tick tock she's referring to
fun baby now you're one of us okay jojo
continue
i was like i don't really mind because
it is true i do have
the most amazing wonderful perfect most
beautiful girlfriend
in the whole world it's not something
i'm ashamed of
i just haven't shown the internet yet
jojo said that while her friends and
family
already knew it was her girlfriend who
really gave her the confidence to come
out publicly
this was the day after i posted the
pointless tick tock
and i was on facetime with her and we
were just talking about it talking about
all the love that came in
and we were both like technically i
still haven't confirmed it
and so i was like i kind of just want to
post this picture on my real story
and she was super encouraging she was
like do it and i was like
all right i love it so much jojo said
that after she came out
she told her girlfriend she knew she was
taking a risk
i was like well technically that was a
really big risk that i took
posting that but i was like but honestly
and she was like why because you could
have lost everything and i was like yeah
but if i lost everything that i've
created
because of being myself and because of
loving who i want to love
i don't want it that's not that that's
not what i want if i can't
if i can't love who i want to love
that's one of the most important things
to me
and while jojo admitted that coming out
can be a very scary thing
she's focused on the people she could
help by sharing her truth
even if there's a million people say
there's a million people that's a lot of
people that don't accept it
there's a hundred million that do but
also i was like i don't want it to have
to be such a big
thing like what am i gonna do like have
a coming out party no it's just who i am
you